dai ma veramente dai ragazzi non ci
fosse che deficente attenzione per e
vabbè che doppietta fatto che mi
lampeggia anche il mouse per quale
motivo
[Applauso]
bella tutti sti cazzi no aspettate un
attimo che sto ma sto registrando quando
iniziare quando registro che ascolto
musica non capisco più cazzo non sono
anche più che lo sta facendo quanto lo
prendo seriamente il mio lavoro da
youtuber e la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovi dio sono farisei perché
ho fatto così siamo attardati ragazzi su
slitte rio è la cosa che volevo farvi
vedere che non avevo ancora visto per
carità se riesco a trovarla ecco ecco la
trovata perfetto illumina veramente ci
siamo ragazzi allora la cosa che non
succedono mai da una vita è quella di
riuscire ad arrivare primi non è più
successo mai è la madonna 8 da affanculo
ce l'ho fatta ho fatto appena venda gli
ho rotto un pò i [ __ ] e importante
quello attenzione ed efficiente era
deficiente ragazzi mi è andata bene è
andata su che cosa vuoi tu levati magda
togli finale la len global globo fatto
su ci potrebbero essere speranze per
arrivare primi non lo so perché sono
partito bene è una cosa che non succede
spesso che io parta bene ce ne vuole
questo muore questo modo me lo sento
sono mora lucido io l'ho ucciso io
lucido io eh vabbè donne vero non sono
morto veramente come ho fatto a non
morire attenzione grosso barca marca
c'ero e va bene va bene anche questo dai
ma contento chi devi togliere non è vero
non è vero non è vero mai ma se mica gli
ho girato in faccia che mi chiedi se
stampato col naso ma neanche
lontanamente vero ma tanto lo sapevo io
che finirà così li prendo io me li
prendo io mi prendo io ti devi togliere
noi il globo male l'ho preso l'ho preso
l'ho preso l'ho preso sicuro perfetto
bella zio mag
stavo morendo io ci stavo morendo con
definisce va bene porca [ __ ] vacca
laida mi sono pagato in mano pure media
non prestare attenzione alle cose che
faccio [ __ ] e la schiena re la
skin più strana che bach e ma cos'è paci
crepa qualcuno son convinto eccoli
io io non potevo morire un secondo
primari mortacci tua
bravo bravo bravo bravo
[ __ ] oggi non c'è verso di fare in
carniere non riesco a fare niente ora
quello ok cosa appena fatto quello che
vi incula it ultima fatica si doni
perchè perchè ti devi [ __ ] tu che
sei brutta e arancione perché è morto
come morto come è morto non lo so va
bene va bene a me non mi interessa basta
che più punti effetto brava donna quanti
punti ho preso a caso ho finalmente un
po di culo dalla mia parte perché non
vai gioco ok bye bye bye bye vado che
cosa è successo
ok mi si è schiantato 1 ragazzi sta
succedendo l'impossibile guarda che
cazzo è matto equa muoio
e invece no strano in genere sono io a
morire in questi casi mi fate uscire da
questo punto che sono ansioso così
uscito in rosa gioco di merda che gioco
di mer faccio l'ultima partita la mia
vita non lo aprirò mai più mai mi sono
rotto il cazzo già già mi è successo di
metterlo scorso perché o sia stato le
cuffie e sempre grazie a sta merda
ora che il milan page anche il mouse per
quale motivo è un segnale di pericolo
per gli e smetti di giocare asta cagata
e io lo ascolto danilo dai vieni danilo
giochiamo insieme che ci divertiamo
grazie danilo pilar culo che se succede
ma da una vanto larga è morto è morto di
pil non ultimo giorno non riuscirete a
quanti cazzo ti pinky sta il primo pam
che gran botta avevano fatto niente non
ho preso niente alla fine di attenzione
per e vabbè che doppiato fatto non era
roba indecente trova via meno la partita
[ __ ] server isfol suisse full of
minchia ragazzi a quanti punti sta al
tipo che sta davanti a me adesso 300 qua
ma stiamo scherzando ma questo è
veramente il più grosso verme che io
abbia mai visto dopo donald trump
io veramente se ammazzo questo ho fatto
la giocata della vita ci ha ammazzato
uno grosso 350.000
punti sarà il mio obiettivo per questa
partita ragazzi tenterò di ammazzare lui
avete capito come giocano questi per
fare per rimanere così avanti
raggiungono stipsi punteggi incredibili
e vanno ai limiti della mappa così
nessuno di rompe il cazzo tranne quando
perché hanno il famigerato rno che caga
i [ __ ]
mi vuoi inglobare ma non mi ingloba
perché è brutto non è vero non è vero ci
riesce bastardo ad un bastardo c'è
riuscito perché non sono non sono
abbastanza grosso da potermi permettere
di uscire quando tenta di inglobarli c'è
veramente un verme di 350 mila punti sta
tentando di inglobare uno che ne ha 10
veramente questa cosa va dai dai ragazzi
tranquilli
ciò solo un verme di 350 mila punti che
sta tentando di esser chiari niente di
che c'è poco una giornata easy hai
presente il detto quello che si dice
prenditela con qualcuno della tua taglia
ecco precisa me non so se lei ben capito
quel dettori e resisterò fino alla fine
della mia vita ma il bollo perché ce
l'hai più grasso è brutto deficiente
vedremo chi ce l'ha più grosso quando
rinasco minchione eh vabbè ci sono di
nuovo qua e se rischio ammazzarne 1
riuscire a tornare lì più in fretta
possibile
che culo toglietevi che devo andare alla
mazza lo gigante se pagato il gioco ma
dai lavora mento mi si è pagato il gioco
mi sono comparse le frecce di quando
caricava dai sembra tipo che io abbia
attivato un superpotere una roba del
genere è la madonna cosa ho trovato che
culo perfetto ora sono abbastanza è la
madonna carmignotto conti punti perché
devi rompermi cazzo a me da ma veramente
dai ragazzi non ci fosse ed efficiente
non è vero che è successo a sta cosa è
morto così non ci posso credere ce ne
vuole essere stupito di me pokémon
condom è iscritto poco nonostante di un
meme ricky la sedia elettrica zio ho
fatto è va beh se siete scemi
vorrei vorrei vorrei ma non può vorrei
mano un posto e dopo 600 ore di ricerche
a dire che con questa roba
spero che fini sia piaciuto ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio prima di
lanciare e spaccare qualcos'altro tipo
le cuffie se viene piaciuto consentono
un momento è un mi piace anche al
processo di facebook come vi adottata
una descrizione se uso residenziale ci
vediamo al prossimo video e magari con
dei vermi un po più piccoli perché ormai
ho perso le speranze massima va da
ragazzi
[Musica]